josée legault martin biron michel david
bonsoir bonsoir alors on parle de
camionnage depuis quelques jours
évidemment on va voir des images il se
dirige le rappelle aux gens vers ottawa
samedi vont culminer là il ya un an qui
ont prévu des dérapages d'autre part on
verra la tension deux choses à la fois
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que là ce qui
au départ était en colère contre
l'obligation vaccinale ça s'est élargit
un peu à peu près toutes les mesures
sanitaires
josé où vous avez comme moi attendu
malgré tout plusieurs camionneurs au
québec notamment dire on n'est pas dans
cette histoire là il faut faire
attention
oui et quand même 90 pour ça le des
camionneurs canadiens qui sont
vaccinées c'est clair que c'est une
minorité
c'est une minorité qui n'est pas
étonnante parce que s'inscrit dans un
mouvement beaucoup plus large qui est
comme vous le disiez non seulement
l'opposition au vaccin parce que
derrière l'opposition l'obligation
vaccinale pousse le dire le sait c'est
une opposition aux vaccins on n'a qu'à
regarder les affiches qui tapissent les
camions qu'on a vu jusqu'à maintenant
mais il ya aussi toute cette
constellation d'extrême droite racistes
g pistachi terol qui est en train de se
greffer à ça et ça ça et qui est
énormément aussi les 90% de camionneurs
au canada qui ont rien à voir avec ça
mais je pense qu'on peut les rassurer en
leur disant que quoi qu'il arrive à
tahoua et on espère qu'il aura pas de
grabuge
je pense que les gens comprennent
prévenu mon cas pas de dissocier entre
ce petit groupe la trêve vocale et très
bruyants et là la presque totalité des
camionneurs finalement parce que martin
on peut avoir un malaise face
habilitation vaccinale on peut un peu
ton est libre mais une chose est ce une
autre chose que d'aller là bas puis dire
on va faire un spectacle devant le
parlement martin parce que c'est le
parlement canadien là c'est une
institution très importante c'est ça
aussi le potentiel de dérapage est très
très élevé parce que c'est pas juste et
non vaccinés long on a rassemblé à peu
près tous les insatisfaits de notre
société c'est un mouvement que port de
l'ouest qui rassemblait aussi que
trouver
des gens aussi en ontario il ya moins de
québécois effectivement et moins de
camionneurs de l'est mais c'est la
question des grades et des personnes du
des mouvements radicaux qui sont en
train de prendre en otage ce mouvement
là et c'est ça qui est plus inquiétant
et c'est ce qui fait que ce soir on peut
pas vraiment prédire ce qui va se passer
en fin de semaine mais on se sait tous
ce qu'est le danger est pas d'éloges
d'ailleurs les policiers sont sur leurs
gardes michel évidemment oui bien
entendu on sait pas moi je suis pas
convaincu du tout que les jeunes vont
prendre d'assaut le parlement comme il
avait pris d'assaut deux capitales mais
simplement la présence là d'un nombre
considérable de gros véhicules qui vont
stationner à ottawa pendant on sait pas
combien de temps là il arrive samedi
mais ils peuvent bien rester quelques
jours il est évident alors que ça génère
un potentiel de problème considérable
maintenant il ya toute la dimension
politique de ça aussi
là on voit que trudeau a tient son bout
il a constaté par un campagnes
électorales et depuis que la vaccination
obligatoire c'est un bon filon pour lui
je pense ça l'avait bien servi à ce
moment là il voit évidemment aussi que
ça embarrasse monsieur autour alors
c'est un jeu qui est dangereux quand
tout le monde la trouve un avantage une
situation qui peut être explosive ça
fait une pas toujours comme on avait
voulu oui monsieur autour d'eux devait
parler d'ailleurs je voulais vous
présenter un extrait n'a pas il a
retardé son point de presse à 18h pour
ça qu'on n'a pas des extraits du chef
conservateur qui est un peu entre
l'arbre et les corses là josé oui mais
c'est lui qui s'est placé leur
volontairement et ça c'est un problème
fondamental avec monsieur o'toole depuis
qu'il est chef du parti conservateur et
des toujours pluie coincé entre sa
frange extrême il ya quand même
plusieurs de ses députés qui ont appuyé
le combo a dit de la liberté et qui ont
dit des choses extrêmement dur l'a
publiquement à écouter même pierre
poilievre a parlé de vet des taux
maximal de la part du premier ministre
canadien
donc c'est comme s'il y avait même pas
le contrôle finalement sur son propre
caucus donc et c'est inévitable dans la
mesure où comme d'habitude il prend pas
une position claire il essaie de ménager
la chèvre
sanitaires et le fou d'extrême droite
dans son parti il observe aussi il faut
le dire quand même toute cette frange
fondamentaliste chrétienne qui est aussi
est persuadé que jésus les protège mieux
que le vaccin et c'est ça aussi on le
voit dans le convoi il ya beaucoup de
monde dans son parti des pro choix de
contre l'obligation vaccinale sont
souvent les mêmes proches loin ainsi les
brugeois l'avortement donc
c'est tout ce mélange là et puis bon ben
je pense que son leadership qui continue
de lui même
j'allais pas michel david non non ça
l'aide papillome monsieur autolog est
pris dans un cercle vicieux c'est à dire
que plus on le critique à l'intérieur de
son parti puis on remet son leadership
en question plus il apparaît comme
un chef faible auprès de la population
alors sa popularité votre diminué c'est
à diminuer les conservateurs elles ont
plus pour le changer alors je sais pas
comment il peut casser ce cercle là mais
vous savez le carton commence à signer
un chef à coups de canif là c'est long
c'est sanglant c'est pas beau ça finit
généralement mal le congrès c'est un
printemps 2023 dans son camp c'est très
loin c'est loin c'est loin ont bloqué
monsieur boileau docteur boileau en solo
petit jeu de mots facile aujourd'hui
flanqué de deux d'experte et de médecins
côté de lui mais on va entendre le
message sur la vaccination
mais il ya bien pris garde de parler sur
le terrain politique sur la la taxe pour
les non vaccinés on écoute sur son
message sur la vaccination
le job nous est propre aux litiges et
les vraiment de santé publique puis ça a
été respectée et tant mieux toutes les
mesures qui peuvent être prises pour
accentuer l'élan vers la vaccination
sont les bienvenus maintenant il s'agit
de mesures économiques et moi je préfère
ne pas commenter sur les mesures
économiques se relève paul de l'
expertise la santé publique
déterminez attention c'est loin d'être
terminé avec les données dans ce moment
mais si tout le monde va se faire
vacciner ça peut se terminer pas mal
vite l'eau alors donc c'est vraiment un
élan le campus se donner tous pour aller
chercher ça alors docteur boileau qui
dit marc tienne je ne vais pas dire si
c'est une bonne idée ou pas que cette
taxe santé qui va commencer à être
débattu la semaine prochaine à québec
mais ce que je vous dis c'est que c'est
une bonne idée de les faire vacciner ben
je passe une petite observation sur
monsieur le témoignage de monsieur
boileau la conférence de presse en fait
d'abord il ne représente aucun danger
pour le politique je pense que monsieur
legault peut dormir sur ses deux
oreilles avec le docteur boileau et jour
apporte à horacio arruda qui allait
témoigner en commission parlementaire et
qui avait tendance à faire quelques
petites gaffes rappelez vous quand il
avait répondu à la question du député
pascal bérubé que c'est pas lui que
monsieur legault est allé plus loin que
ce qu'il avait recommandé en ce moment
les restaurants alors monsieur wallon
n'est pas là et même sur la taxe la
contribution santé ou non vacciner même
pas parlé d'une mesure politique parlé
d'une mesure économique alors on voit
qu'il fait à six qui patine assez bien
les plus de ce labyrinthe cela est
effectivement il y avait un long
plaidoyer en faveur de la troisième dose
en tout en disant que non la vaccination
obligatoire c'était une mauvaise
mauvaise idée ce soit il évite tout ce
qui est première impression jauger
oui bah moi de la méta nomination je
pensais que c'était une bonne nomination
sûr quand même un certain nombre de
plats quoique martin donc tout à fait
raison je série sera pas et ce non
seulement une embarrassera paul premier
ministre contrairement au docteur arruda
mais il a une manière plus habile de se
faire quand même les coûts du premier
ministre sur un certain nombre de
questions dont les citations sur la
ventilation les n95
mais sur la vaccination moi ce qui m'a
plu chicoter aujourd'hui et je comprends
de son point de vue qu'il est qu'il ait
fait ça
c'est que on a oublié les faire dans la
pièce de la conférence de presse qu on a
beau appeler la population à aller
chercher sa troisième dose et il le faut
dans reste que pour moins que le québec
depuis l'automne a pris énormément de
retard par rapport à d'autres états sur
la troisième dose on se souviendra que
le plein d'experts qui lui demandait
avant le micro voix gervais l'homme
maintenant le maintenaient le québec
continue à accuser un record évidemment
et il ya même deux experts qui
commencent à avancer la possibilité que
si on a autant de morts au québec dans
la cinquième vague si aussi en partie à
cause du retard qu'on appuie dans la
troisième dose donc oui vote pour la
paix elle il faut le répéter mais faudra
pas ignorer non plus l'éléphant dans la
pièce tout comme de dire non à la
vaccination obligatoire dès 4 ans quand
on sait que les trois quarts sera
décompté club des complotistes
mais ça veut dire que quand on abandonne
la possibilité de faire vacciner toutes
ces personnes là et je n'écris
aujourd'hui abandonnée et pourquoi c'est
sûr mais pourquoi les abandons pourquoi
abandonner sa et pourquoi abandonner une
autre possibilité si c'est pas la
vaccination directement obligatoire
d'étendre le passeport vaccinale
maximum d'activités de travail les gens
dire qu'on a il est déjà étendu pas mal
conçus non il est pas étendu ou msa ses
prix mais les employés ont pas son
projet avec smiley de lieu de travail
qu'il n'y a pas de règles pas de
passeport vaccinale et ça c'est une
manière d'obliger aussi le 3 encore des
codes 2d non vaccinés qui sont des cons
et complète juste à le faire mais vous
voilà
pour moi ok là bing si la ligne
responsables non mais le docteur bois
nous l'a bien dit ça pourrait se finir
plus vite si la vaccination avançait
plus exactement en même temps gérer pas
dans la vaccination obligatoire michel
mais j'étais vite monsieur mais ce bois
là avait été extrêmement abed parce que
oui à écouter ça c'est une décision de
notre des économies qui auraient pu dire
fiscale je me prononcerai pas là dessus
mais il y avait aussi toute mesure qui
peut inciter les gens à se faire
vacciner c'est une bonne idée alors le
gouvernement peut dire écoutez c'est
précisément sur le but de la taxe la
contribution santé c'est d'inciter déjà
vaccinées alors il ya et il n'y a pas de
liste une bonne idée mais y'a pas dit
que c'était une mauvaise des noms plus
bas alors c'était
impressionnant puis monsieur legault
peut choisir le déséquilibre là ok
l'opposition sur le renvoi les écouter
sur la taxe santé ça reste un débat
compliqué parce qu'ils sont sont comme
pas mal on les écoute ça soulève mille
questions est ce qui ce qu'il nous ce
qu'ils nous ont ce qu'ils nous ont
mentionné d'un point de vue éthique d'un
point de vue légal d'un point de vue
même de l'efficacité d'une telle mesure
il ya énormément de questions qui sont
soulevées et honnêtement moi je a priori
je vois pas comment vas tu en saveurs
emmerder les non vaccinés ce n'est pas
une stratégie de sortie de crise c'est
une stratégie politique d'un
gouvernement que perdu le contrôle
donner des amendes ou non vacciner ça
ouvre pas de lits dans nos hôpitaux le
fardeau de la preuve
il revient au gouvernement de nous
démontrer qu'il ne pas fait ça parce que
des sondages internes lui disais que ce
serait populaire
bon martin un petit mot là dessus le
gouvernement va aller de l'avant avec
cette taxe pour les non vaccinés ouais
mais ça va être un débat à surveiller
parce que c'est la dernière session
parlementaire avant le scrutin du 3
octobre si son projet de loi là dessus
n'était pas adoptée au cours de cette
session là ils meurent au feuilleton
alors est ce que c'est un outil
politique est ce que si les partis
d'opposition s'y oppose jusqu'à la fin
le gouvernement est prêt à sortir un
bâillon pour aller de l'avant avec ce
projet de loi avec cette loi là et c'est
vrai que des enjeux sensibles notamment
la confidentialité des dossiers se sera
pas simple que ça j'ai comparé les
politiquement il ya il ya quelque chose
là ces gens ce que vous dites que vous
pensez qu'ils vont foncer malgré tout
bas le premier minitre semblé tenir
beaucoup mais je pense que martin a tout
à fait raison le débat va être très dur
très serré à l'assemblée nationale non
seulement parce que on s'en va à
l'élection évidemment dès le début de
l'automne mais aussi parce que c'est une
mesure qui est qui et qui très
questionnable sur sur plusieurs plein
donc encore une fois
l'argument pourquoi emmerder les
non-vaccinés lorsqu on pourrait faire
autre chose genre étant de passeports
vaccinale je reviens là dessus il ya
d'autres manières de le faire
ça je pense que ça va
devenir
si michel gym d'un appareil si on est à
comme vous dites josée lepage pas
vaccinale dans pleins plaines du far too
pourquoi ne pas appeler un chat un chat
puis de direction jacques six nations
obligatoire alors un michel tait parce
que leur ont fait part en arrière ce
qu'on veut pas faire part en avant mais
ils veulent pas le faire si
je pense je pense que
légalement ils pourraient le faire à son
bras qu'il y avait des contestations
mais en bout de l'île il ya d'autres
endroits sur la planète là qui sont pas
des gens qui se fiche complètement des
droits et libertés fondamentales qu'ils
ont fait et les tribunaux leur ont donné
raison et je pense qu'en bout de ligne
ça arriverait mais je pense que monsieur
legault pense qu'il peut faire
l'économie de ça parce que la situation
s'améliore tranquillement mais sûrement
et je vous dirais que c'est la même
chose pour la taxe santé yves haut
niveau m le projet il va le présenter il
va le faire débattre mais je suis loin
d'être certain mois qu'il serait prêt à
mettre un bâillon là dessus tant que le
débat fait et ce fait est qu'il s'avise
your ça s'améliore et il sait aussi que
les gens sont généralement favorables à
cette mesure là alors il lui il va
simplement mettre le fardeau sur sur le
dos de positions qui vont dire en écosse
est épouvantable alors que les gens sont
pauvres alors il y aura pas besoin de le
faire adopter si vous voulez pour pour
obtenir le gain politique de ce projet
intéressant bon on se repasse je vais
vous parler du troisième vingt mais ça
va être une autre fois de l'opposition
que les libéraux leur opposition est
encore plus clair il n'est pas question
dans la région de québec comment tout ça
va résonner marty mail aux folles on va
se revoir à plusieurs reprises merci au
revoir bonne soirée au gras
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh